on a été rejoint en plateau par
Véronique Ithurbide monsor Véronique ça
va bien ça va et vous ça va très bien et
comme chaque mardi c'est vos insolites
que vous présentez au téléspectateurs TV
c'est ce sont même vos insolites et on
commence Véronique avec la sortie du
nouveau Guide Michelin qui a fait grand
bruit on a entendu beaucoup parlé de la
perte de la 3e étoile de Guy Savoie mais
dans les Yvelines qu'est-ce qu'on peut
retenir de ce guide Michelin 2023 et
bien moi j'ai retenu que dans les
Yvelines nous avions six étoilés dont
trois concentrés à Versailles
imaginez-vous alors voulez-vous savoir
lesquels bien sûr si vous me dites NON
je suis un petit peu déçu alors on y va
merci
au grand contrôle on a Gabri les
ravazziaux qui est je la prends du sel
italienne mais bon c'est pas Gordon
voilà et puis évidemment la table du 11
avec Jean-Baptiste Lavergne moradini qui
que j'avais reçu en vibre d'ailleurs en
2018 quand il avait écrit un livre voilà
qui est un petit un jeune qui qui marche
très bien qui a aussi le Bistrot du 11
voilà pour les trois étoilés versaillais
on a vu donc les restaurants étoilés
Illinois s'afficher on a la petite liste
alors parmi cette liste il y a aussi un
étoilé un insolite c'est l'étoile verte
qu'est-ce que ça récompense alors en
fait l'étoile verte c'est une sorte de
label qui a été donc créée en 2020 donc
toujours par le guide Michelin et qui en
fait
demande enfin pour l'avoir pour
l'obtenir cette étoile verte il faut
bien sûr être éco-responsable
locavore comment dire chasse au
gaspillage alimentaire
durabilité tout enfin dans mes tiques
environnemental circuit court va tout ce
que tout ce qu'on aime en ce moment tout
ce qu'il faut faire voilà alors là la
personne qui a gagné qui a eu cette
étoile verte elle s'appelle Sibel idlow
c'est une chef américaine elle vient de
San Francisco elle est mariée à français
et son restaurant s'appelle la ruche
d'ailleurs je crois qu'on en parlera sur
cette même chaîne bientôt un reportage
on a eu quelques images en
avant-première du lieu c'est du côté de
Gambais on aura un reportage
effectivement très prochainement et
juste pour terminer ce lieu elle aurait
la 2000 m² de potager 80% de la
production se retrouve
à sa table elle fait son pain elle fait
son beurre et ça Ricote voilà donc elle
coche plusieurs cases est-ce que vous
savez s'il y a de la il y a de la tente
déjà pour aller pour aller dans ce
restaurant
faut toujours attendre un petit peu dans
la vie
négligeable pour ces restaurants on va
continuer Véronique avec une vente aux
enchères historiques qui a lieu ce
dimanche à Versailles il y avait
notamment une boucle de cheveux de Louis
xviette le dauphin le dauphin une page
d'écriture aussi toujours de Louis XVI
pas de bêtises mais c'est surtout une
lettre historique qui a été comme on dit
le clou de la vente tout à fait alors
cette vente elle s'est passé chez
Jean-Pierre au Sénac un commissaire
prisseur avenue Saint-Cloud à Versailles
et trois fois par an cette commissaire
préserve organise des ventes
spécialisées autour de la royauté ou des
objets de la Révolution par exemple vous
voyez mais alors ce qu'il dit c'est
qu'il y a des choses très chères on peut
aussi avoir un lot à 100 euros il y en a
pour tout le monde voilà alors là cette
fois-ci le Cloud du de lavande c'était
justement de cette lettre c'est la seule
lettre qui reste de Robespierre qu'il a
écrit à son ami Danton pour le
le réconforter parce que dans ton venait
de peindre sa femme en couche et donc
comme un très bon ami qu'il était il lui
écrit une lettre extrêmement
réconfortante et d'ailleurs je peux vous
en lire un petit morceau si vous voulez
on a vu la lettre s'affiche à l'écran
mais allez-y déjà non
pas du tout
mon cher Danton si dans les seuls
malheurs qui puissent ébranler une âme
tel que la tienne la certitude d'avoir
un ami tendre et dévoué peut t'offrir
quelques consolations je te la présente
et il ajoute dans cette lettre je t'aime
plus que jamais et jusqu'à la mort
et c'est étonnant mais je vais vous
laisser continuer je vais vous laisser
ça c'était écrit le 15 février 1793
imaginez-vous qu'un an après presque
jour pour jour qu'est-ce qui qu'elle
mouche le pique Robespierre ordonne que
ce pauvre Danton soit guillotiné alors
moi des amis comme ça merci mais non
merci voilà mais il faut savoir qu'à
l'époque déjà la rivalité entre les deux
hommes commençait à poindre et
apparemment cette petite pointe arrangée
je sais pas si on peut parler le
Thermomix
la mèche de cheveux du petit dauphin
avec un autographe de Marie-Antoinette
Louis XVI 23000 c'est acheté par un
collectionneur normand c'est un
collectionneur parisien qui a acheté la
lettre et il y avait aussi cette page
d'écriture du Louis Charles qui s'exerce
à écrire son prénom à signer qui a été
vendu 18000 euros
voilà cette voilà
on termine avec du cinéma une
avant-première le 21 mars à Versailles
avec un acteur ivinois et quel acteur
Jean Dujardin ce jour-là alors une
avant-première à Versailles le mardi 21
mars à 20h30 vous avez donc liquide du
film Jean Dujardin le film s'appelle sur
les chemins noirs pardon de donner
Imbert il y aura aussi le producteur du
film qui s'appelle Mathieu voilà enfin
ça c'est mes feuilles je comprends plus
rien mais tu veux faire et alors ce film
en fait il a été adapté librement d'un
livre de Sylvain Tesson qui a aussi
écrit le scénario j'imagine avec le
Denis Humbert Sylvain Tesson qui a eu un
terrible accident il y a quelques années
et qui après a effectué une très longue
marche une espèce de
reconnaissance de soi de quête de
plongée dans la ruralité et il a fait à
pied du Mercantour au Cotentin il a
traversé vraiment prend sa pied et donc
ce film est inadaptation de du livre
voilà et j'ai un dernier petit truc de
dernière minute encore de cinéma il faut
soutenir le cinéma franchement c'est
important et surtout classé une bonne
nouvelle c'est le Cyrano qui organise
une séance spéciale de 20 roues mourir
le dimanche 19 mars à 18h30 avec à
nouveau l'équipe du film pourquoi pour
les récompenser parce que le Cyrano a eu
les meilleurs scores pour ce film en
meilleur score de France en janvier
février c'est une histoire de pendant la
guerre de Vendée de révolte paysannes
etc donc voilà c'est riche il y a
beaucoup de choses à avoir au cinéma et
il faut en profiter donc cette date ce
sera le 19 mars
et le 21 mars ont du jardin voilà
enchères et en gastronomie lettre de
Robespierre cinéma qu'est-ce qui vous a
le plus intéressé Samuel un peu tout
pour ces enfants insolites
[Musique]
de réapprendre cette histoire de
Robespierre et de Danton
oui je la connaissais mais vous avez
toujours à porter un petit plus donc
merci je suis forte merci beaucoup merci
Véronique on vous retrouve mardi alors
vous étiez pas là la semaine dernière
mais on vous retrouve bien mardi
prochain vous le confirmez au
téléspectateurs de TV7